Hello everybody welcome you are very
very welcome we are Match Day minus one
which is one day out from the World Cup
which is very exciting it's of course
been very very controversial but I think
once the World Cup gets going it'll grip
us the way it always does now um the
thing that fans really hate at a World
Cup apart from a lack of beer is when a
decision goes against you and it's wrong
Maradona the hand of God in 1986 putting
England out of the World Cup when it
should never have been and then of
course Argentina went on to win it these
days that happens less and less because
of VR and because of technology and this
world cup will be a lot closer to 100
accuracy by referees it will never be
100 but will be a lot lot closer why is
that technology has moved on and this is
a good point to introduce Tracy kit who
is the CTO of Hawkeye right now very
welcome Tracy thank you we are are going
to talk about the latest technology in
just a second the semi-automatic
off-site technology but first of all for
those who are not involved in sport and
not interested in sport particularly I
mean I know all about Hulk I am very
familiar with it
um what has Hawkeye done I wanted I was
going to say to change sport but really
I should say to evolve Sport and you've
been very much involved in tennis and
crickets and of course goal line
technology sure good morning everyone
thank you for having me today
yeah so Hawkeye Innovations has been
pioneering change in sport for over 20
years so we deliver best-in-class
officiating uh broadcasting and
performance technology to over 25 Sports
across the globe currently and that
includes uh being technology provider to
the FIFA World Cup for semi-automatic
offside as you mentioned goal line
technology and VAR so we're really
privileged to be here today to talk
about our technology and how it's helped
to
evolve the way sport is engaged with how
it's participated and Health and Welfare
of officials and players not not only in
football but throughout tennis as you
mentioned in cricket and then globally
so in the US we have many sports that
we're working with there including
baseball and so yeah it's really
exciting for us to showcase our
technology on a global scale and yeah in
something like tennis it's really added
to the sport because the excitement in
the stadium is the ball in is the ball
out I mean that's incredible this new
semi-automatic offside technology is
something that is is fairly new it's a
highly accurate VAR video assistant
referee you all know that um but but
what technology is involved how does it
work
so in terms of semi-automatic offside we
have around 12 cameras in the stadium
that is tracking accurate ball and
player positioning using skeletal data
through Optical tracking techniques and
so we're able to see exactly where a
person is on the pitch at around 50
frames per second and so it gives us a
really accurate view of where everyone
is at each point in time and it gives us
an idea where the ball is and so then we
can determine whether someone is offside
or not and we can send alerts then to
the the VAR operators and officials to
then investigate whether that is truly
an off-site event so we really are
providing the supporting tools and and
technology that facilitates that
decision making but the decision making
is still the result of the officials on
the match yeah and actually offside is
one of those things where sometimes even
we've seen with VAR you know you still
can't get it right because the because
the video angles aren't quite good
enough and there is still human error
involved but hopefully this will wipe
that out a little bit well technology is
as I said it's a supporting tool so we
we it does allow the officials to have
more accurate and faster decision making
and a more informed decision making so
the amount of cameras that we're using
gives more more angles for for the
officials to to make that judgment
decision but it is still a judgment
decision by the officials on the day
to ask you actually so Harry Kane can't
run along you know Iran score a goal you
know next week he suspects it's offside
he goes offside let me have a look no he
can't do that absolutely not okay no the
players the players are not allowed to
signal to have a VAR review
um and the coaches are not allowed to
signal that as well we are checking
constantly in the backgrounds in the
officiating areas any sort of events uh
that that needs to around penalties and
so forth and so we're always looking
um in real time whether there is an
event that needs to be assessed but only
the officials can can make that judgment
call and call a bar review or alert to
an offside event so it is still a human
decision you still need a human
absolutely that's why it's called too I
mean it's called semi-automatic offside
not or medical so yeah absolutely
absolutely it has been quite stopped art
hasn't it um VAR
you know so far the average time for an
offside decision this is a FIFA start is
70 seconds which is over a minute which
is a long time in a football match which
is meant to be free-flowing and is you
know it's not American football it's
meant to just keep going and also you
know the idea that you can't celebrate a
goal anymore until it's been checked by
VAR and how quick is this oh it's within
seconds so as mentioned we are regularly
throughout the entire game through
skeletal tracking and our ball tracking
technology assessing where everyone is
on the pitch and so whenever there looks
to be an offside event we can instantly
send that to the officials who within
seconds can review and assess whether
that is in fact an off-site event and so
then they signal the the referee on the
pitch so it's it's seconds compared to
what it is for VAR I think this is a
good time to have a little look at the
video because the graphics are so
impressive and if we have a little we're
picking it up the video is already
talked about the ball that's going to be
used at the World Cup which has got a
microchip in it which is also tracking
information as to when the ball is
kicked so we're picking up the video up
a little bit late but let's join it now
12 dedicated tracking cameras mounted
underneath the roof of each Stadium
track the ball and 29 Points on the body
of each individual player 50 times per
second calculating their exact position
on the pitch
the 29 Points include all Limbs and
extremities that are relevant for
offside calls allowing the team in the
video operation room to know the exact
position of a player at any given moment
how accurate is that line
it's very accurate so we we use all of
those body points to determine exactly
where the player's position is and their
extremities and we use the ball tracking
sensors and Technology as well to
understand exactly where the kick point
is so that helps us triangulate through
AI
whether where that line needs to be
drawn and whether there's an offside
event so you can see on this one the toe
is just over the line relative to the
kick point of of the player
how um what's the correct phrase how
small can you go could it be literally
half a toenail and and you'd know
absolutely
it's very accurate it's very accurate
and we've had we've had lots of
independent scientific uh validation of
our technology to ensure that accuracy
for for our federations and leagues that
we work with and for football
and so we regularly ensuring that
accuracy fully official so they can make
those right judgment calls and be
confident in our technology
how long did this take to develop and
where has it been tested because there
is no way FIFA would allow this just to
appear at a World Cup unless it's been
really really really tested sure so
we've been working with football
um federations and leagues since since
the last World Cup to look at how
technology can further evolve the sport
of football and and what does that look
like what are the needs of officials and
referees and and fans who are engaging
with that Sport and how do we introduce
technology to bring that forward and so
since the last World Cup we've been
working on this we've tested in over 300
uh sort of test events since then and so
we've given V for the confidence they
need that our technology is fit for
purpose and of quality and is accurate
what's the feedback bin I mean have you
had feedback from from from the VR
referees and do they find it easy to use
absolutely I mean it's it's very simple
to use we are providing the right tools
and techniques for them to make that
that quick judgment as I said it's
within seconds they need to make that
decisioning so our technology needs to
be you know easily accessible and easy
to use so that they can make that
decision making you know we've been for
over 20 years we've been trying to make
sport you know fairer more engaging uh
more informed uh and safer for not only
referees and officials but also for
players
um and so we've had really good feedback
from our technology and we've been
pioneering change across multiple Sports
as we talked about before with tennis
and so forth so the VAR um referee he
sits in a different room you know in the
in the Premier League for example he's
not even at the match he's in stockley
park so where will they sit do they need
a Hawkeye person with them or do they
know it well this is automatically
appear in front of them
if the referee on the pitch says I'm not
sure about that I think it might have
been offside
sure so some in some places the
the people are on site the officials who
are making the decisions and some in
some leagues it's off-site in a
centralized location so we have a
operator from our team who's who works
with the VAR to give them the right
camera angles that they need for example
for bar to make decisions there
um and we also are checking constantly
in the background with this with this
technology to to look at whether there
is an offside event that's happened so
our tracking cameras are real time
tracking you know the 29 body parts and
the players positioning on the fields
all throughout the game and so our Ai
and systems are looking at Whenever
there is an event that could that does
look like it's an offside event it does
alert it sends an alert to where the VAR
officials are sitting whether that's
remotely or centralized and then they
check instantly whether that is in case
uh in that case an offside decision and
if it is so they'll alert the referee on
the pitch to then you know make make
that call and then we will visualize
graphically as well for fans in stadium
uh that decision making so we're making
it more transparent as well for fans to
be involved in that decision making now
so we can virtually recreate in 3D the
replay of that off-site event so you can
see as you've seen on that on that
screen the millimeters that are involved
in that decision whether it's a knee or
a toe or a fingered joint it definitely
resolves arguments very quickly before
they even start doesn't it the pace of
the game go as well right so by us
checking in the background constantly
any event and the system alerting to any
event it allows the flow and the pace of
the game to continue and the referees to
keep keep that pace and momentum going
as well so during the matches at this
world cup you said that the fans in the
stadium will be able to see it do they
see at the same time as the linesman or
the referee for example or is it a delay
of the graphics appearing on a screen
uh so once the officials have made their
decision then we can virtually recreate
it for the fans in the stadium so that
they can see why the decision has been
made as it has been made
um which really helps fans really engage
with that process and it's it's a really
cool visual representation of what's
been happening yeah and it sort of adds
something to the event as well because
there's sort of that Split Second of was
it wasn't it absolutely and I think
you've never been involved or able to
see that sort of Replay to that depth as
well and virtually recreating it in 3D
gives you another dimension to see that
play and how it's how it's been decided
as well it's much more accurate than um
than what we've had before yeah so you
can see it in the stadium if you're
there what about if you're watching at
home which is that you know let's be
honest that's where most people are
going to be watching most of their
football and you're going to be able to
see it at home as well absolutely I mean
today we have that capability through
broadcast Sue in Syria and UEFA we've
been lucky enough to work and partner
with them as their technology provider
and we've been virtually recreating and
replaying visualizations of off-site
events in those leagues and then in
future absolutely and more and more
events we'd love it to be broadcast not
only just live you know on TV but
through multiple mediums your mobile
phone social Etc
but for this world cup we are not going
to see this
on our screen in stadium you will in
stadium but not on your TV not currently
no FIFA didn't want that we don't know
why
um you're Gathering a lot of information
during a match 180 million pieces of
information
per player or for the whole for the
match as a whole I mean that's a lot
it's a lot of data points which gives us
really great opportunity to use that
data for various other use cases with
skeletal tracking so in the future I'm
really interested personally in um like
health and well-being of the referees
and officials and the players and how
can that skeletal data help inform you
know how is your body moving you know
are you moving in a way that is can
cause injury are you being hit in a way
that's causing injury
um you know are you is your performance
can it be improved through changes in
the way that you're kicking a ball or
throwing a ball or catching a ball and
so all of that data that's collected and
analyzed we use in different ways so we
can use it through health health and
well-being for players but we also use
it to recreate virtually through our
sister companies with Beyond Sports
who's now just come on board into our
family you know we're able to take that
data and turn it into a 3D World you
know they've got blocky avatars that
they're using with tracking data to
recreate live a game that you can watch
alongside a real events you can watch it
in a gamified way so it's really
exciting stuff that we've got there and
then with our other sister company
pulseley were able to take that data and
digitalize it into you know web and app
experiences and and fan engagement
experiences that we've we've never had
before so I must say a lot of data I
think it's quite spooky there's so much
data and so much limb data for every
single footballer on that pitch do you
think maybe going forward there might be
a situation where you know that data
could be fed back to the managers that
they know if a player is is tiring
particularly or you know the way that
they are kicking is not as efficient as
it was at the beginning of the game and
they know actually maybe we should take
this this player off I mean sometimes
it's so very obvious that a player's
tired but sometimes players hide it very
well absolutely and that's why I said
like our technology is a support tool
for coaches as well as officials so that
data can help them better understand the
help of well-being of their players on
the pitch but also while they're
training as well and that can help them
with their improvements of their
performance both on the pitch and off
and for me it's really important that we
are using that data in the right way to
help help and help help players be the
best they can be but also prevent injury
that's really important yeah so this is
just for offside uh what would the
graphics we've just seen But Hawkeye
already do the goal line technology
explain how that works the goal line
technology so it's similar we have the
tracking cameras and broadcast cameras
that help us understand exactly where
the the ball is and and we can see the
the goal line and it can determine then
whether or not the ball is going over
the line or not through that Optical
tracking and we feed that information
back to the video referees to make that
decision on on whether it's over the
line or not and then we send a link
sorry we send alerts then to the referee
on the pitch to determine to advise them
that we believe it's a goal or not a
goal where were you in 2010 when Frank
Lampard stole that goal against Germany
and it was over the line and they said
it wasn't over the line love to have
been there
um so do you think in future um handball
for example I mean that's another big
shot we get from the players during
matches handball
do you think actually you use this
technology to determine whether someone
actually has handball or not I mean
absolutely our technology is capable of
tracking as as we mentioned the 29 body
parts on on the player on the pitch at
all times and we're tracking the ball so
we can absolutely determine whether it's
a handball or not so it really is just
us working with our partners of ceremony
you know what do they need for the
betterment of their sport how can we
help them with our technology in order
to improve officiating for that specific
sport not just in football but across
multiple you know the 25 Sports I
mentioned that we're working with we
have lots of technology that can enhance
their game and it's just really working
with them to determine how do we
introduce that in a way that is
cognizant of you know the legacy of the
game the humanness of the game
um and so it's a journey really and
bringing that into in into each
individual sport yeah without changing
the sport too much perspective of that
Legacy of the sport and we want to be
cognizant of that and work with Partners
to ensure we're protecting that as well
as advancing towards technology and
bringing that that to the full on that
subject have you faced many barriers
when you've you know you've come up with
this amazing technology and sport is
quite resistant to change I could
imagine in tennis that was very
difficult to get you know Hawkeye over
the line and definitely with FIFA it was
very difficult to get that ball over the
line when you're talking about goal line
technology Palm completely intended but
have you have you met with much
resistance or is that now gone away a
bit
I wouldn't say it was resistance I think
for us as mentioned like our our role is
to partner with those sports leagues and
federations to better understand their
needs and how we can help enhance their
game and so we are working tirelessly
with them to understand how is that
technology today versus where it needs
to get to how do we evolve that together
what does that Journey look like you
know how will fans react to that how do
they want to engage with our technology
how do they want to engage with that
Sport and so we find a balance and what
does that balance look like because
ultimately it's all about the fans and
how they're engaging and you know we
want to make it successful for them but
also for the players as well we don't
want to disturb the flow of their game
so it's a real a fine art for us to
ensure that we're meeting the needs of
everyone
um but you know we are the ingredient
where the providing that that tool and
that support mechanism for them it's
definitely improved sport it's
definitely improved the outcomes it's
improved the efficiency of a lot of
sports do you feel with the with the
younger generation there's been a
generational shift and we're almost out
of time but do you think almost the
younger generation embraced this so much
that actually they would like a lot more
technology oh absolutely we are in a
generational shift
um the younger audience and fans engage
with sport in new and different ways
that my generation for example didn't
you know they've grown up with
technology they expect technology in
every part of their lives and whether
and how they view content you know where
they want to view it how they want to
view it is different to how I I grew up
and so we need to be cognizant of that
and deliver you know more detertainment
to them more engaging immersive
experiences for them you know whether
that's through virtual Recreation
immersive headsets and blocky avatars
the metaverse you know all of that is
open to us and really exciting for me
and my businesses in order to go after
but we have to be cognizant of the other
Generations as well right because
everyone is a sports fan so our
technology needs to speak to all
generations and we need to work with our
partners to figure out what is that
balance
and thank you so much Teresa CTO of
Hawkeye really interesting talk I mean
the referee's job is still safe but I
mean I I can't I can't really say that's
going to be the same for him in 10 years
time also it's still essential they make
the final decision so they are
absolutely essential have a good World
Cup thank you very much
[Applause]